a new book raises questions about
whether the federal government is doing
enough to ensure the safety of generic
drugs coming into the United States 9
out of every 10 prescriptions filled our
generics that saves Americans some 3
billion dollars a week over the cost of
brand-name drugs and many of those
generics come from abroad with 80% of
active ingredients in 40% of Finnish
drugs coming from outside the US and a
Werner spoke to several people who are
concerned about efforts to inspect those
overseas facilities and it's a story
you'll see only on CBS this morning Anna
good morning good morning Nora we've all
heard that generic drugs are basically
the same as brand-name drugs after all
they have the same active ingredients
and their manufacturers are supposed to
prove that they work the same way as
their brand-name counterparts but are
all of those drugs manufactured overseas
really this name I'm thankful that I'm
still here
when we met Cedric Brown he was in the
hospital for a foot infection but that
was a big improvement from seven years
ago when his heart failed and he
underwent a transplant did you feel
really different after you got the
transplant definitely I feel great the
operation was a success but months later
Brown's condition deteriorated and he
came back to the Cleveland Clinic where
dr. Randall Starling found Brown's body
was rejecting his new heart we had to
figure out why why did this happen to
Cedric
doctor Starling discovered that the
brand name anti-rejection drug Brown had
been taking called Pro graft had been
switched for a generic manufactured in
India you look at this bottle and I take
it questions were immediately raised in
your mind immediately questions because
that particular drug was on a list of
generic medications his Hospital tries
to avoid prescribing to its patients the
FDA says a generic medicine is the same
as a brand-name medicine in dosage
safety and quality but experts at the
Cleveland Clinic I've determined some
generics aren't a close enough match for
their comfort that even a small variance
in the drug may pose serious risks for
some patients so you can't take the risk
that a drug is just slightly less than
what the patient needs or
maybe more in a given patient that's
high risk for rejection there may be no
leeway whatsoever
I remember him seeing it was the
medication because what happened to me
and so then did things get better after
that it's a window into a larger problem
says investigative journalist Catherine
eben this is all I have done for the
last five years she wrote a book called
bottle of lies
she says the problem is that the u.s.
relies on information submitted by drug
makers in order to approve their generic
medications but some overseas
manufacturers aren't being honest there
are many companies in the industry that
are falsifying their data falsifying
data straight out straight out fraud the
first major fraud case came to light 14
years ago that of Indian generic
manufacturer Ranbaxy the company paid a
half billion dollar penalty as part of a
2013 settlement for selling adulterated
drugs and making fraudulent statements
to the FDA former Ranbaxy executive
Dinesh the core was the whistleblower on
the case are they the poster child for
how bad things can get I wish I could
say that I've seen similar to behavior
another company since 2013 so they're
not the only ones even says a major part
of the problem is the FDA's efforts to
regulate overseas drug production our
entire drug supply has changed now these
drugs are overseas and the FDA is forced
to be a global agency so the question is
is it up to the task or not and how well
is that going for them did you find very
badly she explains that while FDA
inspectors in the u.s. often show up at
plants unannounced overseas companies
are frequently warned weeks in advance
that inspectors are coming but these
inspections that are taking place
overseas are essentially staged
inspections staged what do you mean by
staged they're staged by the companies
the FDA told us in a statement that it
inspects all brand-name and generic
manufacturing facilities around the
world
says it's conducted a number of
unannounced inspections at foreign
plants when the agency has information
from a whistleblower or when the FDA is
investigating a drug safety issue but
this former FDA investigator told us
when he and others dug deeper into the
records of those companies they found
serious problems
did you see problems that you considered
to be fraud yes we're not showing his
face or using his real voice but reports
he and other inspectors filed show they
found numerous generic drug makers
falsifying records covering up
manufacturing problems and attempting to
hide poor test results if the data is
not accurate or if the data is falsified
what do we know what the drug is that's
coming out on the end for sure we would
question the safety and efficacy of
those drugs yeah the FDA says it's
modernized its policies in recent years
and that Americans can be confident in
the quality of the products the FDA
approves
but those inspection reports came as
unwelcome news to doctor Starling my
initial reaction is anger to falsify
information to manufacture and make a
profit on a drug it's just
unconscionable to believe that that
could happen well the group that
represents generic drug makers disagrees
it says the industry is contributing
hundreds of millions of dollars to help
the FDA increase the frequency of
inspections and it notes if there are
issues going undetected by the FDA there
would be severe health issues in this
country so and I watch the story and I
just think it's so scary so how do you
know where your generic drugs are made
where they're coming from you know it's
a really difficult thing one of the
problems here is the sort of the lack of
public information you can ask your
pharmacist which company made your
generic generic medication but you're
gonna have to do some research to figure
out whether that company has ever had to
recall products or has been found to
have had manufacturing issues and it's
really difficult if not impossible to
find out whether
we're the companies actually make the
drugs as in which country the FDA told
us that that's considered confidential
information under federal law it's very
disturbing because I could ask the
question they could tell me the Warner
company I wouldn't know what that meant
for those of us who do buy generic drugs
a lot it's it's very disconcerting yeah
and and and for certain patients who
need these sort of very these drugs that
apply in a very narrow range um that's
where some of these risks come in
according to the doctors at the
Cleveland Clinic because the the the
dosage has to be so specific and so
exact that if it's not it runs the risk
of affecting their transplant and almost
cost somebody his life mm-hmm thank you
careful thank you Anna